ooh nice tonight a ranch get freaked out
like 99 ranches or those Asian
supermarkets because they would always
have toads in a tank oh yeah
there's no up Asian supermarkets is a
place where you can get any part of an
animal that you can think of because
when I grew up a lot of these
supermarkets didn't carry the type of
protein of produce that we needed as you
know as an Asian family and they just
didn't carry it so these Asian
supermarkets will pop up and they would
provide the stuff that we need remember
when I was a kid and there was like this
tray full of pink stuff that straight
doesn't beat and I asked what there was
and said uterus was big it was pig
uterus it was like a circle it's a pig
uterus what what traditional Asian dish
has pig uterus in it there's a grandma
probably knows how to make a dish yeah
and then with a lot of it's almost like
somebody must really like pig you ready
just sell everything man I don't know I
guess I kind of enjoy the fact that
Asian people have this concept of not
wasting your food and making sure that
you utilize everything that you have but
something should be left alone like pig
[ __ ] I'm gonna always forever love
immigration in the United States because
without that we won't have the
traditional Asian grandma that's the sad
thing though because like the more
modernized our society becomes we don't
we're not going to get that in the next
like 3040 years and that's just going to
disappear when we're grandparents as
that that's not
yeah I think I'm just going to walk
around trying picketers just forgot my
foot is do this is traditional Claudia
nation pig [ __ ] soup 99 Ranch is one of
those really well known commercial Asian
supermarkets that all of us go to in
Sacramento before our 99 Ranch popped up
we do have a 99 F match now arrived yet
um we had what we market been fat at
these places were so dope but they were
dingy is like the weirdest place I've
ever been
like an edge right typically when you go
into a 99 Ranch you do expect it to be a
lot more cleaner than some of the
smaller supermarkets but still generally
there naseous you have like toads in a
bucket here and there you got turtles
that you thought as a kid you're taking
home as a pet but next thing you know
you're eating this delicious soup and it
was your turtle named Alfred you day no
I don't know like chickens head like
ethnicities and surely I pre-cut chicken
so I didn't punch it again I didn't know
there was something called black chicken
in the first place that's why how do
people come on I got that young chicken
and I got a young chicken everything's a
shout out to my boy young chick young
chicken is still kicking I'm saying this
is the cleanest 99 wrench I've ever been
to in my life
I'm gonna always go here the craziest
thing about the 99 wrench that we went
to it was clean
as [ __ ] almost too clean where I didn't
like it because the cleaner a 99 Ranch
is the less pig uterus they have meaning
they don't have all that unique [ __ ] it
was a little too commercialized for my
taste
I kind of even though I complain about
the old Asian grandma's like the weird
dirty [ __ ] here and there I kind of miss
it
I want it it doesn't feel like an Asian
supermarket if you don't have a little
bit of the dizziness and the grudge that
it usually has yeah we're like the
screaming grandma yeah we actually don't
even run into a single Asian grandma
which is disappointing you know I kind
of want to be you know yelled at and
cursed at and told them a piece of [ __ ]
even though I'm not the grandchild hey
this makes some sense no yeah you see
that shopping cart school a whole bunch
of products this is how it should be
lunch in me this is like poor man's
family yes nobody can use fan this poor
man's me vagina ham
very old vagina vagina ham is
specifically located next to the country
where you get ball set carrots yeah
that's what everybody get it the good
[ __ ] right here free crabs chase I know
it's crab [ __ ]
I used to get this brand at the flea
market so it was just like adidas but it
wasn't a date it was called ideas yeah
but II was a little sure I seen that I
had like Hello that she did so if you
guys ever grow up broke like I did and
you know I told you guys that I used to
work at a flea market and a lot of these
flea markets have terrible cops
absolutely terrible and that was the
only [ __ ] that I could afford and
specifically I had this sweater or even
a lot of t-shirts that said ideas which
was a knockoff of Adidas so they could
they would take one of the beads in the
middle and they were shorten it so it is
a completely [ __ ] up and I spotted
that [ __ ] like it was real until I got
called out of elementary school Thank
You auntie for that by the way this is
dude what was his name he was Reggie he
is Jordan sure thought he was rocking it
and then we looked at he got at a flea
market
it said Jordan so this study it was I
and I think Jordan was doing a layup
let's just cute as hell what would it
Japanese Japanese manners you know a lot
of the times when you guys go to these
Asian restaurants and you get like a
mayo sauce or something like that and
you're like oh how come my mail doesn't
taste like that that's because that [ __ ]
is QP mail QP mail is the [ __ ] secret
ingredient msg yes 99 Ranch has become
so official to the point they're trying
to battle bonds and Safeway they have
those membership cards I forgot what the
deal was I think like if you spend $100
you get like $1 back every dollar you're
a point that's been Allison box you get
$10 that's ridiculous
all I know is that I'm an official
member of 99 Ranch [ __ ] y'all
it started